this morning's mass shooting we just
discussed is the latest in a series of
high-profile gun attacks
in washington this morning president joe
biden said he's going to do something
about it
today he announced a new series of
executive actions on new gun control
measures
deborah alferon has the details from the
white house
president biden is taking steps on his
own to enact
new gun safety measures we have an
opportunity to fulfill the first
responsibility of government
to keep our people safe today's actions
include orders for the justice
department to draft red flag legislation
that states can model to keep guns out
of the hands of people facing mental
health issues
the department will also have 30 days to
create new rules addressing ghost
guns self-assembled weapons that require
no serial number
and president biden wants a 60-day
review of how stabilizing braces for
pistols
are regulated a stabilizing brace was
used in last month's boulder colorado
mass shooting
the accessory enables pistols to fire
like short barreled rifles
and makes them more accurate greater
stability means greater accuracy and
control
the white house says today's actions are
just a first step
they've offered plenty of thoughts and
prayers members of congress
but they passed not a single new federal
law to reduce gun violence
president biden also plans to name a gun
control
advocate to head up the department of
alcohol tobacco and firearms
david shipman a former atf agent has
been an advisor to the gun control
organization
set up by former arizona congresswoman
gabrielle giffords
vice president harris and i believe he's
the right person at this moment
for this important agency the nra issued
a statement saying
it will fight this nomination and
ill-conceived executive actions
deborah alfarone cbs news the white
house